This is a download from BBC Learning English.
To find out more, visit our website.
6MuteEnglish
from BBCLearningEnglish.com
Hello and welcome to 6 Minute English. I'm Alice.
I'm Neil.
Neil, how often do you do the washing up at home?
Oh, you know on special occasions, like after Christmas lunch.
That's terrible, Neil.
Well, domestic chores are the subject of today's show and you know what?
I'm not very good at them.
Hmm.
Domestic means to do with a family or home and a chore is a boring job that needs doing.
Not being good at chores sounds like a bad excuse for a voiding housework, Neil.
I suppose you're right, but I wasn't surprised to learn that an average
women spend several more hours a day doing chores at home than men.
Maybe men have a higher threshold for dirt and untidyness.
Hmm, do you have a high threshold, Neil?
Yes. And threshold means the point at which you begin to feel something.
It takes a lot of dirt and untidyness to make me feel I need to start clearing up.
Okay. So my question for you today, Neil, is what percentage of men take responsibility
for giving the house a weekly clean, according to a recent online survey by UK
organisation Mum's Net? Is it a 1%, b 5% or c 10%?
Hmm. Those figures all sound low, but I'll assume that not all men are like me and say c 10%.
Well, we'll see if you're being optimistic with your answer later on in the show.
So now let's listen to a conversation between BBC reporter Jeff Bird and his wife Sarah
in an interview to a BBC presenter they discuss Sarah's a version to or strongest like of domestic
chores. I think it's a boring thing. You should just do the minimum amount you need to do to get
by. That is my policy. And I'd say I definitely work hard for new to and therefore have less time.
And we just switch stround in terms of our roles. Probably, yeah. And that's no bad thing. Go
to the revolution. Sarah and Jeff there in their household, Jeff does more chores because Sarah
finds them boring and she also does more paid work. She thinks people should do the minimum amount
of housework or at least amount needed to get by. And to get by means to achieve something with
difficulty. So Jeff does most of the cooking and cleaning in their house, which as we discussed
earlier on isn't usually the case for men. He doesn't seem to mind though does he?
Well, no, that's right. He says switching roles is no bad thing. In other words, it's a good thing.
Yeah, go the revolution. Just don't include me because I'm with Sarah. I hate housework.
Okay, well, let's assume that Sarah and Jeff aren't typical of most families and consider
the serious implications of women doing more of the household chores. Some domestic tasks can
be strongly gendered or specific to one sex. For example, doing the laundry, organizing your
children's school and social lives are often jobs that women do. But putting the rubbish out or
fixing a leaky tap, those are what many people still see as men's jobs. Well, I put the rubbish
bins out in my house, Alpnil. Anyway, this means women often spend significantly more time doing chores
at home, juggling this with paid work. Yes, that sounds like a lot. I can see I'm going to have to
get my penny on a bit more at home, Aless. I hope you do, Neil, because a bit more give and take at
home could help improve a working month's prospects of getting promoted at work and earning more.
And for those of you unfamiliar with the word penny or pinnifor means apron. And give and take
means compromise. Let's hear now from Professor Jonathan Gershney, co-director at the Centre for
Time Use Research at Oxford University, talking about why it's important to protect your earning
capacity or ability to earn money. Nowadays, half of all marriages fail. It's not a reasonable
expectation that you're going to stay married for the same chap indefinitely. And if under these
circumstances you've been out of the labour force looking after the kids while he builds up his
earnings capacity by working long hours at work and then he runs off with his secretary,
well, he departs with the earnings power and you're left with the baby.
Professor Jonathan Gershney, but actually these days quite a few men take care of the children
while their wives or partners work full time. And she might run off with her secretary.
But the main issue here is that both partners, whether male or female, should protect their
earnings capacity. Now, I think it's time for the answer to today's quiz question, Neil.
I asked you, what percentage of men take responsibility for giving the house a weekly clean,
according to a recent online survey by the UK organisation Mum's Net? Is it a 1%
b, 5% or c, 10%? And I said c, 10%. And you were wrong, I'm afraid, Neil.
The answer is actually b, 5%. Mum's Net asked nearly a thousand working mothers about the
distribution of tasks in their homes. Now, can we hear the words we learned today, please?
Sure, they are. Sure. Threshold. Aversion. Minimum. No bad thing.
Gendard. Pity or pinnacle. Given take. Earning capacity.
Well, that's the end of today's 6 Minute English. Don't forget to join us again soon.
Bye bye.